الطاقه بلف مهم جدا في هذه الفتره لعبت
دور مهم ايضا في اعاده تشكيل المشهد
الدولي والحرب في اوكرانيا النمسا هي
واحده من البلدان المعنيه مباشره بهذا
الملف هل هناك سياسه جديده تجاه هذا
الموضوع
لهذه الحرب لانها موسكو مضت
بتسليح الطاقه
مع روسيا منذ عام 1968 لدينا عقود مع
الشركات مثل غاز لتزويدنها بالغاز
عاليه جدا يتمنون بالمئه من الغاز من
روسيا اما الان فقط خطبنا تلك النسبه الى
20% ونقوم بتنويع مصادر الطاقه
على مصدر واحد فقط ولكن مصدم ان تقوم
بدوله مثل روسيا والتي كانت مصدرا معتمدا
بغض النظر عن حقيقه ان لتحسبتي انهار او
او سقطت الستار الحديديه روسيا كانت مزودا
معتمدا للغازي لروسيا لان سواء ولكنها
تتغير بعد فبراير 21
من الاعتماد على الغاز الروسي